Here's what I see, the first thing I'm looking at is the file structure and
from that I call tell that we probably have two views.
One thing is called app view and one thing is called to do view now I'm
choosing to explore my file and folder structure here in sublime text.
But you could also do it here in the finder, it's just not necessarily as
easy to see everything at once here I can open up multiple folders at once and
see all of the files inside.
Now, I can infer from the naming of these views, that this one is the view for
the entire application and this one is the view for each to-do item and
speaking of to-do items, we also have a model for our to-do.
To-do.js.
Now you may also remember that we also have things called collections at least
that's what they're called here.
In Knockout, we called them observable arrays and from the name,
I can infer that this is probably just a collection of to do models.
So we've got two views, we've got a model for each to-do,
we've got a collection of to dos, and then we also have this router thing.
And if you remember from before, although we haven't used them in this class,
routers are just like views, but for the URL instead of the page itself.
Now there's also this weird thing called Bower now what the heck is that?
Well one simple way to find out is to Google it if we search Bower,
we get bower.io and we click.
It says Bower, a package manager for the web.
So if you've never heard of Bower before, you can just read this web page and
it'll give a high level overview of what it is.
It says web sites are made of lots of things, frameworks, libraries,
assets, utilities, and rainbows Bower manages all of these things for you.
Now I'm not going to get into any more depth of what Bower is but
feel free to explore it on your own suffice it to say,
it keeps track of all of the various libraries that we're using.
Now, what libraries are we using?
Let's go back to our editor, and
we'll look at all the things that Bower is holding on to for us.
We've got Back Bone, we've got Back Bone dot local storage we've got jQuery,
we have to-doMVC Common and we have Underscore.
Now let's make a couple of guesses, of course you can Google these things and
make those guesses a definite, but I am going to guess that because to to-doMVC
is a project, where the same app is built in all of these different frameworks.
To-doMVC comment is just going to be a bunch of
assets that are used in all of those various projects a CSS file,
a base JavaScript file, and it looks like a background dot PNG.
Those are just resources that are common to all of our to-doMVC projects.
We're only working with ones so we don't have to really worry about what that is
now, if you explore a little bit further, you will find that that base dot
CSS file is the only CSS file that we're going to be caring about.
If you need to make any changes to the CSS, you can feel free to do that.
And in fact if you open it up and you look through,
there have been some changes that have been made by me specifically so we
can get ready to do all of the various things we're going to add to the project.
Let's take a moment to look at all these others jQuery.
We've talked about jQuery before.
jQuery is a DOM manipulation library it also let's you
make AJAX calls to servers and has some good utilities.
If you need an overview of jQuery, go ahead and take a look at the website and
if you need more in-depth jQuery, feel free to take a look at our course on it.
We've got BackBone and BackBone.localstorage.
Now who knows what BackBone is maybe you do.
But maybe you don't.
So let's Google it BackBone.js aha!
BackBone js gives structure to web pages by providing models,
collections and views.
So it looks like this is our model view whatever.
This is our organizational library BackBone.js if we
go back to our code there's one more: underscore.
So what's Underscore?
Well once again we can hop over and Google it.
Underscore.js.
Underscore.js is a JavaScript library that provides a whole mess of useful,
functional programming helpers without extending any built in objects.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So it looks like Underscore just gives us a bunch of utility functions,
which makes it easier to write JavaScript.
Now, they talk about functional programming, that's beyond,
way beyond the scope of this course.
But even if you don't get into functional programming at all,
Underscore.js does have a whole mess of useful functions.
And sometimes it's nice to include Underscore rather than
reinventing the wheel over and over again.
Let's explore a little bit more.
If we go to our index.html file.
The page that gets loaded,
we'll notice a couple interesting things here were loading our CSS.
Base.CSS exactly what we were looking at before.
And if you go to the very bottom of the page, you'll see all of the script tags.
Loading to do nbc common base.js jQuery Underscore BackBone,
BackBone.localstorage, which I'm going to guess is a plug in for
BackBone to work with local storage.
And then all of our JavaScript files to-do in the models.
Collection, both views, the routers, and app.js and
if we look around a little bit more, we'll notice these peculiar script tags.
Normally you have script, without a type, or
with a type of text slash JavaScript.
In this case it says text/template so these represent snippets of
HTML that our JavaScript can use to display things in our app.
For example, item template is going to be the template for
displaying a to-do item.
If we ever wanted to make changes to the way our to-do items render.
This would be a good place to do it,
because this is the template that they render based off of.
So let's return to those questions really quickly.
The library whose name starts with a u is Underscore.
The organizational library that is used to separate our concerns is BackBone.
How many views do we see?
Two views, app view and to-do view and
hopefully this all makes enough sense, that we are comfortable moving on